[Musique]
le concept est assez simple l'état veut
réduire le nombre de prisonniers à petit
peine en priorité ils sont dit qu'ils
allaient mettre à l'épreuve dans une
prison dans les enfermant mais en leur
laissant une chance de s'échapper s'ils
font preuve de cohésion de solidarité et
d'un peu de logique ils ont une chance
de s'échapper en moins de 60 minutes de
la prison
on a choisi en fait de faire des salles
d'un à peu près du même niveau qu on
appelle de niveau intermédiaire on est à
peu près sûr du sur deux 50% de réussite
sur sur toutes nos salles qu'on trouve
que c'est le sait le mieux pour les
joueurs parce que les joueurs aguerris
il trouve pas ça trop simple 50% et
quand même un groupe sur deux qui arrive
pas en moins d'une heure et les groupes
débutants ils arrivent quand même à se
débrouiller y en a qui peuvent réussir
alors que c'est leur première escale via
[Musique]
le game masters il va jouer ces indices
en fonction de l'avancée des joueurs en
fait il va avoir deux buts le premier
c'est d'intervenir le moins possible
pour que l'expérience appartiennent aux
joueurs et qu'ils se débrouillent le
plus possible par eux-mêmes qu'ils y
prendront plus de plaisir mais il va
être aussi là pour débloquer pour pas
rester 20 minutes sur une énigme sinon
bah des joueurs vont s'ennuyer lapin
d'intérêt donc ces façons son rôle est
fondamental parce que c'est lui qui
donne le rythme au jeu
donc on est quelques années en arrière
en 1679 tout simplement et donc à cette
époque il ya des empoisonnements à la
cour de versailles donc le roi louis xiv
et affaiblit son pouvoir royal est
affaiblie donc il va demander à louis ii
l'aréli qui est lieutenant général de
police d'enquêter sur 7 sur cette
affaire on a fait des scénarios on a
fait les énigmes par nous mêmes et puis
au niveau des décors on a travaillé en
fait avec des professionnels du théâtre
qui ont fait ou des charmes sur
eurodisney des choses comme ça
[Musique]
on a fait deux qui sont un peu plus
difficiles que les autres qui sont donc
sortir ou mourir est tchernobyl on
communique pas trop sur le taux de
réussite l'idée pour nous c'est que on
va aider un peu plus un groupe qui est
un peu plus en difficulté forcément et
puis laissez un peu plus se débrouiller
les meilleurs
[Musique]
il faut de la fouille il faut la logique
il faut de la réflexion et cetera mais
le plus important c'est comment on
arrive forcément une équipe ont contre
trois et six joueurs chez nous parti et
moi on a un élément faut que toute
l'équipe soit courant et donc l'idée
c'est dada fois que tout le monde soit
courant sans se parler tous par dessus
des uns les autres moi je vais commencer
à faire les bougies donc la
communication gérance est la première
qualité